- [Instructor] My history professor,
who always criticizes me for being late,
missed our scheduled review session.
So you could tell just in how I read it,
I had to put a pause here in
order for it to make sense.
In order for who always
criticizes me for being late
to describe my history professor.
So ideally, I wanna put a comma
at the beginning and
the end of this clause,
that is describing my history professor.
I don't wanna keep it the same.
I wanna put a comma at the
beginning and at the end.
So I like that choice.
Now, let's look at these other ones.
My history professor, dash,
who always criticizes me for being late.
You could separate this clause with a dash
but you'd wanna separate
with a dash on either side.
So if you put a dash here,
you'd wanna put a dash right over there,
which is kind of a,
you could view it as a
stronger parenthetical.
My history professor,
who always criticizes me for being late,
missed our scheduled review session.
I always view the dashes like,
make sure you're seeing this thing.
It's you know, hey, I'm
really gonna make it clear,
this is the person who always
criticizes me for being late.
So it would have been an option
if they had a dash on
either end, but they don't.
So we're gonna rule this one out.
And for the same reason,
they only put a dash at the right side
but not at the left side,
so I would rule this one out as well.